this video is brought to you by nordvpn
give yourself options online go to
nordvpn.com forward slash biographics to
get a two-year plan with a huge discount
plus four additional months for free
more on them in a bit
there's no doubt that leland stanford
deserved the title robert baron he
relied on unscrupulous and immoral
practices to achieve his fortune he used
his influence as governor to benefit his
private businesses he rallied against
immigrants but then used them to build
his railroads because they were cheaper
and yet this is not how he's usually
remembered lynn and stanford managed to
shed the stigma of ruthless robber baron
that still applies to many other rich
industrialists of his time mainly thanks
to his philanthropy in his later years
whether or not this is deserved you can
decide for yourself as we explore the
life and the man behind america's first
transcontinental railroad leland
stanford
[Music]
stanford was born on march the 9th 1824
in vaterfield new york a town that no
longer exists as it's been divided into
several other towns his parents were
josiah stanford and elizabeth phillips
both descendants of immigrants who
originally settled in massachusetts
before moving to new york state leland
was their fourth son and he had seven
siblings including a younger brother
thomas welton stanford who went on to
relocate to australia where he became
known as the country's father of
spiritualism after founding the
victorian association of progressive
spiritualists jose stanford was a farmer
and a pretty successful one at that but
he still insisted that all of his boys
worked on the farm growing up that is
what leland did and his education was
split between the local school and
homeschooling when he got a bit older
leland was sent to the clinton liberal
institute prep school in clinton new
york and afterwards he studied law at
casanova's seminary in 1845 the 21 year
old leland stanford moved to albany
where he apprenticed at the law office
of wheaton doolittle and hadley in 1848
he passed the bar and relocated to port
washington wisconsin where he opened his
own practice as a present for him his
father had assembled for leland a law
library which was said to be one of the
most extensive in the entire country
around the same time leland stanford met
and fell in love with jane elizabeth
lathrop the daughter of a successful
merchant from albany the two got married
in 1850 and would go on to have one
child together leland stanford jr two of
stanford siblings died when they were
young but of the remaining six leyland
seemed to be the only one willing to
settle down and lead a quiet life all
the others moved across the country to
california tempted by all the new
business opportunities provided by the
gold rush this interested leland as well
but he seemed reluctant to leave his
current life behind at least that was
until 1852 when his entire home burned
down including his beloved library with
nothing keeping him in port washington
anymore stanford packed up his bags and
headed out to california while his wife
returned to her family in albany new
york and waited for him to get settled
later that same year stanford made his
way to michigan city california known
today as michigan bluff and opened a
general store there it did pretty well
due to its optimal location in the heart
of mining country stanford was liked and
respected by his peers and also served
as a justice of the peace he stayed
there for a few years before selling the
place and returning to his wife in
albany now that they were better off
financially the couple executed a
permanent move to california this time
settling in sacramento where stanford
did business with his brothers
[Music]
throughout his life leland stanford
showed an interest in politics once he
was settled in california he became an
active member of the newly formed
republican party which mainly consisted
of former whig party members he attended
the first convention of the california
republican party and he was named a
delegate and began running for office he
first was a candidate for state
treasurer in 1857 and then governor in
1859 but he lost both elections since
the opposing democratic party had a
strong foothold in the state stanford
ran again for governor in 1861 and
things went differently this time the
rublings benefited from turmoil within
the democratic party over the issue of
slavery some were against it while
others particularly in the south
defended the practice since there was no
way to find common ground the party
divided into two the democrats and the
southern democrats they each performed
their own candidate and basically split
the democratic vote almost down the
middle allowing the republicans to swoop
in and win the election on september the
4th 1861 leland stanford became the
first republican governor of california
his inauguration was on january 10 1862
although it didn't really have what you
would call an auspicious start at the
time california and the surrounding
states were experiencing the great flood
of 1862 which still remains the largest
in california's history in the months of
december and january the state saw
almost 43 days of continuous rain the
rivers flowing down from the sierra
nevada mountains turned into powerful
and violent torrents that swept away
houses and even entire shanty towns on
the day that stanford was supposed to be
inaugurated in sacramento the city's
levees broke causing a 10-foot high
flood to swallow the streets even so
stanford insisted on holding the
ceremony so he was taken to the capitol
building by rowboat afterwards he rode
back to his mansion and stanford to get
inside his home through a second story
window because the first floor was
entirely submerged this lasted for
months forcing the new governor to
temporarily move the state legislature
to san francisco we have a first-hand
account of the devastation from surveyor
william brewer who visited sacramento in
march two months after stanford's
inauguration he said such a desolate
scene i hope to never see again most of
the city is still underwater and has
been there for three months a part is
out of the water that is the streets are
above water but every low place is full
cellars and yards are full houses and
walls wet everything uncomfortable no
description that i can write will give
you any adequate conception of the
discomfort and wretchedness this must
give rise to the new capital is far out
in the water the governor's house stands
as in a lake churches public buildings
private buildings everything a wet or in
the water not a road leading from the
city as possible business is a dead
standstill everything looks forlorn and
wretched many houses have partially
toppled over some have been carried from
their foundations several streets now
avenues of water are blocked up with
houses that have floated in them dead
animals lie about here and there a
dreadful picture i don't think the city
will ever rise from the shock i don't
see how it can one of stanford's first
initiatives as governor was to begin a
long-term project to raise sacramento's
entire downtown district by 10 to 15
feet so that something like this would
never happen again as far as his other
policies go stanford was also credited
with cutting the state debt in half
helping to preserve california's forests
and keeping the state in the union
during the civil war he only served as
governor for two years in fact he was
the last to do so before the length of
the mandate changed to four years one
controversy stemming from stanford's
time as governor was his heavy stance
against chinese immigrants whom he
referred to as an inferior race in his
inauguration speech he said asia with a
numberless million sends to our shores
the dregs of a population there can be
no doubt that the presence of numbers
among us have a degraded and distinct
people must exercise a deleterious
influence upon the superior race and to
a certain extent repel desirable
immigration it will afford me great
pleasure to concur with the legislature
in any constitutional action having for
its object the repression of the
immigration of the asiatic races this
caused some backlash for the governor
not because of the words but because of
his hypocrisy stanford was against
chinese immigration but at the same time
he had no problem using them as cheap
labor to build his railroads it is
unclear how much of this affected his
political career but he was not
re-nominated for a second term and in
fact he did not hold another political
office after the governorship for two
decades okay so more about leland
stafford just a bit but first a quick
word from today's video sponsor nordvpn
we've talked about the benefits of vpns
before on this channel look it's not
1999 you shouldn't be using the internet
like it is bad actors are out there
trying to steal your data and your
personal information corporations are
tracking your browser activity and
bombarding you with ads
well no one needs any of that nonsense
that's why nordvpn is so crucial it's
based over in panama which makes it a
fantastic option for both americans and
europeans and look a common
misconception of the vpns are just for
people who want to play defense but
they're not just for protecting yourself
you'd be amazed at the different
streaming options you have when jumping
on a server from a different country so
protect yourself or just play around buy
it for yourself or consider it as a gift
for another internet user in your life
with nordvpn you've got lots of options
plus a 30-day money-back guarantee if
you decide it's not for you there's
never been a better time to enhance your
online experience with nordvpn's head to
nordvpn.com forward slash biographics
that's nordvpn.com
forward slash biographics or just follow
the link in the description box below
and let's get back to the railroads
[Music]
the same year that leland stanford was
elected governor of california he also
embarked on a business endeavor that
turned him into one of the richest men
in america like many of his fellow
robber barons stanford invested in the
railroad it all started with a civil
engineer named theodore judah after
planning and building several regional
railroads he believed he had surveyed a
viable route to traverse the mountains
of california and into the neighboring
states this section could then be joined
up with other railroads to form what was
at the time the most ambitious
engineering project in american history
the first transcontinental railroad
judor organized a meeting in sacramento
where he outlined his plans but most
other attendees bulked his ideas one man
didn't and his name was collis p
huntington he was one of the city's most
successful merchants he held a private
meeting with judah and he told the
engineer that he would find more men
willing to invest in his plans those men
were banker charles crocker merchant
mark hopkins and leland stanford
together with huntington they were known
as the big four the main investors
behind what became the central pacific
railroad or cprr with stanford serving
as president of the new company u.s
congress chartered the rail company in
1862. that same year congress also
passed the pacific railroad acts in
order to promote the construction of the
transcontinental railroad obviously
things were made much easier for the
cprr because its president also happened
to be the governor of california in fact
throughout his entire two-year term
leland stanford used his political
influence to assist his private business
also securing land grants loans and
other benefits construction on the
railroad began in earnest in 1863
handled mainly by charles crocker
leland's stanford also devoted himself
to the railroad industry once his
governorship had ended but it seems that
he had a habit of frustrating his
business partners by either staying
silent for days on end or for coming up
with harebrained schemes crocker
described him as being awful lazy and as
someone who needed somebody else to
follow him or to stop the leaks and do
the work whereas huntington considered
his management style to be the circus
despite tensions between the big four
and other problems that came along the
cpr was built at a rapid pace thanks in
no small part to the 15 000 chinese
immigrants who constituted the bulk of
the workforce used to lay down the
700-mile railway that started in
sacramento and ended in utah although he
rallied against immigrants as a
politician stanford changed his tune
when he saw the savings since he didn't
have to pay them as much as american
workers or provide them with living
accommodations a similar thing was
happening with the eastern railways
except that they mainly relied on irish
labor instead of chinese the central
pacific railroad was completed on may 10
1869 when it was connected to the union
pacific railroad to form the first
transcontinental railroad this happened
in promontory utah and has been hailed
as the first mass media event in the
united states it was celebrated across
the entire country almost in real time
thanks to telegraph messages and the
numerous journalists and photographers
who were on hand document the momentous
occasion a golden spike was used to
symbolically join the rails of the two
companies and the man who drove it in
was none other than leland stanford
forever linking his name to one of the
country's most ambitious and most
successful endeavors central pacific's
first locomotive was also named the
governor stanford in his honor the end
of the project also did not mean the end
of stanford's involvement in the rail
industry afterwards the big four sought
to extend their railroad monopoly and
began in california where they either
bought or built other regional railways
which were consolidated with the cpr a
particular importance was the southern
pacific company and a subsidiary
southern pacific railroad which in time
would grow to become bigger more
successful and more important than the
central pacific railroad in fact in 1885
cprr was leased to the southern pacific
company and remained a subsidiary before
being officially merged
[Music]
we're not involved in railroads or
politics leland stanford had a few other
interests to keep him busy and he was
the kind of man who liked to go big in
all of his pursuits he got into wine at
one point so stanford bought two
vineyards and turned one of them the
great vina ranch in tahima county
california into the largest winery in
the world he also developed a fondness
for horses so stanford found at the palo
alto stock farm where he bred racehorses
this inadvertently led to a landmark
moment in photography when standard
approached english photographer edward
muybridge in 1873 and asked him to take
a photograph of one of his favorite
horses during a full gallop at the time
muybridge considered this task
impossible just a few instantaneous
shots had ever been taken and these were
under exceptional circumstances and none
of them featured a horse at high speed
even so he gave it his best shot and the
end result was a blurry image that
nevertheless pleased stanford who wanted
to fund mybridge to refine his technique
over the next few years muybridge had
other things on his mind including a
murder trial for killing his wife's
lover but once that was sorted out he
went back to working for stanford that
original image from 1873 has never been
published but a new much better one from
1877 has showing stanford's horse
oxidant being driven by jazz tennant
with stanford's money muybridge was
ready to try something revolutionary he
called it chrono photography and it
represented a series of images taken in
quick succession which were meant to
show the movement of an object basically
a precursor of motion pictures in 1878
edward muybridge made history when he
photographed stanford's horse sally
gardner using 12 cameras arranged to
trigger one after another which showed
the full motion of a horse during gallop
it was something the world had never
seen before and muybridge did a whole
series of them although the practice
fell out of favor with the arrival of
motion pictures there's a legend which
says that the whole reason why stanford
funded bybridge's research was to settle
a 25 000 bet over whether or not a horse
lifts all four feet off the ground
simultaneously while running although
the tail remains popular it's never been
substantiated by historical evidence yes
in case you were wondering a horse does
lift all of its legs off the ground at
the same time during a gallop but only
when they're tucked inside and not when
they're outstretched while leland
stanford's contribution to photography
was important it was not what turned him
into a household name neither was his
political career or his development of
america's railroads but rather it was
the university that bears his name but
that's not technically correct although
everyone calls it stanford university
and assumes it's named after the man who
founded it its official moniker is
actually leland stanford junior
university and it's named after leland
and jane stanford's only child lil
junior who tragically died in 1884 at
the age of 15 after developing typhoid
fever while on a european vacation with
his parents in his honor his parents
decided to open university and like with
everything else leon stanford did he
went big he used most of his money and
most of his land for the new school and
even that was almost not enough stanford
university opened its stores in 1891 but
by that point its main benefactor was an
ill man long suffering from a disease
which affected his movement called
locomotor ataxia leland stanford lasted
two more years dying of heart failure on
june 21 1893 aged 69 at his home in palo
alto his death caused financial troubles
for stanford university further
compounded by federal lawsuits against
stanford for failure to repay loans the
economic depression of 1893 and later
the 1906 san francisco earthquake which
caused a lot of damage to the campus but
eventually stanford university became
one of the most prestigious institutes
of higher learning in the entire world
educating countless nobel laureates road
scholars macarthur fellows pulitzer
prize winners and even one american
president assabet hoover was part of the
university's first ever graduating class
of 1895. his fellow robber baron turned
philanthropist andrew carnegie described
stanford's bequest as perhaps the
greatest sum ever given by an individual
for any purpose an act which undoubtedly
had a great influence on the development
of engineering medicine and science in
the 130 years that followed and
ultimately became leland stanford's
lasting legacy
[Music]
normally when the subject of a
biographics dies it's about time for us
to end the video but that's not actually
the case with leland stanford because
one of the most interesting events
surrounding him happened 12 years after
his death a murder mystery and a
cover-up both involving his wife who was
killed with strychnine on february 28
1905 and her death remains unsolved to
this day after her husband's demise jane
stanford mainly preoccupied herself with
the administration of the university
where she sometimes butted head with the
board members and professors including
the president of stanford university
david starr jordan the strange event
surrounding jane stanford actually began
a month and a half before her death when
it is likely that her killer first tried
to poison her and failed on the night of
january the 14th 1905 jane stanford was
at home in her san francisco mansion she
had a glass of mineral water before
going to bed and noted that it tasted
very bitter immediately her throat
started to burn so she forced herself to
vomit a mate and secretary ran up to see
what the matter was and they both tasted
the water and agreed that it was
unusually bitter the next day they took
it to a chemist who confirmed that there
was enough strychnine in the bottle to
kill jane stanford in just a few minutes
the 76 year old survived this time but
was left deeply disturbed by this
attempt on her life needing time off to
recuperate jane stanford planned a trip
to hawaii back in san francisco rumors
of her attempted poisoning were quelled
by the university president david starr
jordan who insisted that mrs stanford
was seeking warmer climates after a bout
with pneumonia the time spent in hawaii
did her well at first however on
february 28th mrs stanford was in
honolulu checked in at the moana hotel
she ate a big lunch so for supper she
just had some soup and afterwards she
asked her secretary bertha burner for
some bicarbonate of soda to treat her
upset stomach burner did as instructed
and later that night after 11 pm she was
woken up by cries coming from mrs
stanford's room the old woman was in
pain and said that she'd been poisoned
again the secretary went to get the
doctor but this time it was too late mrs
stanford's last words were this is a
horrible death to die before being taken
over by violent spasms and then finally
succumbing to the poison it was stricken
again which had been found in the
bicarbonate of soda jane stanford was
surrounded by three physicians when she
died and they all said that her symptoms
appeared to be those of strict mean
poisoning then an autopsy found
strychnine in a system and a coroner's
jury reached the conclusion that jane
lathrop stanford came to her death from
strychnine poisoning said strychnine
having been introduced into a bottle of
bicarbonate of soda with felonous intent
by some person or persons to this jury
unknown you would think that all of this
would make it pretty clear that jane
stanford was killed with strychnine but
that was not the case thanks to david
starr jordan who immediately began to
work on a cover-up to indicate that mrs
stanford died from heart failure he
traveled to honolulu take him with him a
san francisco detective and hiring a
local doctor both of whom agreed with
jordan's own assertion that jane
stanford died of natural causes the
university president even accused the
victim's personal physician of adding
the poison to the bicarbonate of soda
after her death in order to disguise his
own incompetence when it came to
treating his patient back in the
continental u.s jordan's statement
carried more weight than the
investigation performed in honolulu so
his version of events became the
official story for over half a century
as to why he did it we're not really
sure it could be that he simply did not
want any kind of scandal associated with
university or it could be that he wanted
to deflect suspicion from himself since
everyone knew that he and mrs stanford
did not get along and there were rumors
that she intended to have him removed
from the presidency unfortunately due to
his actions jane stappard's poisoning
has never been properly investigated
so her death remains a mystery
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching
[Music]
you